ROMAN NURIK: All right,
I think we're live.
All right, so assuming that
we're live, hello everybody,
and welcome to this
week's episode of
Android Design in Action.
We don't have a theme or topic
this week, or any set of
redesigns today.
What we'll be doing instead is
having a hangout with a bunch
of folks from the design
community.
I don't know if this is public
and free to join--
not free to join.
If you're able to join.
If you, for some reason, cannot
join and you do want to
join, just go to the Google+
page for Android developers
and leave a comment on this
post, and we'll go ahead and
invite you so that
you can join.
So we're just going to have a
Q&A general discussion type
event today.
Before we get started, let's
do some quick introductions
for folks that are
already here.
I'll start.
So I'm Roman Nurik.
I'm on our Android Developer
Relations Team at Google, and
I'm one of the co-hosts of
Android Design in Action.
ADAM KOCH: Hey guys,
Adam Koch.
I'm also one of the co-hosts
on the show.
If we go over to London.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
So, Nick Butcher here, another
Android developer advocate.
And I'm joined by--
CHRIS BANES: Chris Banes is also
one of the dev rel for
Android, but I'm a
guest this week.
I don't usually come
into this.
Who else have we got?
ROMAN NURIK: All right, should
we head over to Marie?
MARIE SCHWEIZ: Hi, I'm Marie.
I'm an Android designer for four
years, and now in Berlin
as creative director
for Novoda.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome.
And Juhani?
JUHANI LEHTIMAKI: Hey guys.
So I'm Juhani.
I'm a developer, but
I'm a design fan.
I've wrote a book Smashing
Android UI and write a blog in
androiduipatterns.com, and
I work for Snapp TV.
ROMAN NURIK: Cool.
All right.
So, Dandre was here,
and then he left.
Let's head over to Andreas.
Andreas, do you want to
introduce yourself?
Or if you want, do you have any
immediate questions you
want to ask?
Or not, OK.
Let's head over to Dandre.
How about you?
How's it going, man?
MALE SPEAKER: Hey,
can you hear me?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, we can
year you just fine.
MALE SPEAKER: Dandre.
I'm an Android developer and
designer from San Francisco.
ROMAN NURIK: Cool,
welcome, man.
And we also have Lucas.
Hey Lucas, how's it going?
Do you want to introduce
yourself real quick?
LUCAS ROCHA: Hello,
can you hear me?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, we can
hear you just fine.
LUCAS ROCHA: OK.
So, I work for Mozilla.
My day job is Mozilla, working
on Firefox for Android.
And I also created an
app called Pattrn.
It's a wallpaper app.
We've got quite a few downloads
in Google Play.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, it's been
featured numerous times.
Good stuff.
All right, let's see
who else is here.
I think David Jones.
I'll go ahead and unmute you,
good sir, and Ron Elam.
So, if anybody hasn't introduced
themselves and
wants to, feel free.
Otherwise, let's jump into the
meat of today, which is kind
of general discussion and Q&A.
So before, we actually have a
Google Moderator page set up,
and we have a few questions
in there.
We'll get to that if there's
time, but if anybody has any
initial points of discussion or
topics they want to raise,
or questions that you want other
folks to provide their
feedback on, please
go ahead and ask.
So anybody want to kick things
off with their own questions
or points of discussion?
No?
NICK BUTCHER: No one's
got any questions?
Perfectly satisfied.
JUHANI LEHTIMAKI: I have a topic
we can discuss, but I
don't have any questions.
ROMAN NURIK: Sure.
Juhani, you want to go ahead
and introduce the topic?
JUHANI LEHTIMAKI: So, the up
and side navigation, or the
drawer navigation.
It's great, right?
But it's quite messy
right now.
So we've got to figure out how
to [INAUDIBLE], because now
even Google applications
work quite differently.
Google+ you can't swipe, and
YouTube you can't swipe to
other navigation
apps and so on.
I wonder if you guys have a
recommendation what you feel
the interaction should be.
Should you reserve a bezel swipe
for it, or does swipe
always work?
And my personal opinion about
the icon is that it's the up
icon, but I know you
guys haven't--
but let's see what's going
to happen with that.
Mostly about the interaction
like swiping and stuff, how
you feel as to that?
ROMAN NURIK: So I guess we could
probably talk about the
navigation drawer, and I'll
probably take up some time.
And that was actually
the number one
question in the moderator.
I think it got something
like 20 votes.
I actually put together a little
bit of, not really
documentation.
It's the unofficial
recommendations from our team
about what we've been
recommending to folks publicly
as well as internally.
And we could probably
start with that.
So let me just share that real
quick, and then as you guys
want to talk about what your
feelings are towards the
subject, then feel free.
So I'm going to screen share
my tiny little guide on
navigation drawers.
I don't know if you
guys can see that.
You guys can see that?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
ROMAN NURIK: So the current
guidelines are, basically, a
drawer is a slide out menu that
allows users to switch
between views of your app.
And it's obviously exposed using
the action bar's app
icon with the up current and
revealed by an edge swipe.
And actually in some cases like
the YouTube app, it's not
really an edge swipe, it's
a full screen swipe.
Anyway, that makes sense, and
personally, my opinion is that
it makes a lot of sense to do a
full screen swipe when there
aren't competing gestures.
For example, if you don't
have swipe to dismiss--
Actually, hold on.
AJ just joined.
Let me go ahead and unmute AJ.
Hey AJ, how's it going?
So when you don't have swipe to
dismiss, or you don't have
other horizontal gestures like
for example a map as your
primary content view, I think
it makes sense to do a full
screen swipe, because that's
probably what people are
trying to do anyway.
That's just, again,
really my opinion.
And the current guidelines say
edge swipe, and I'd say that,
by default, you should
probably just
used the edge swipe.
The other thing is that--
where is it--
only suitable for the
topmost level.
So another thing that folks
sometimes use drawers for--
and hold on, let me
unmute David.
He just joined.
The other thing that people use
drawers for is to provide
exposed global navigation
throughout the app.
For example, if I'm in a detail
screen three levels
deep somewhere, what if I want
to expose global navigation,
let the user do a full
context switch?
And sometimes folks use
drawers for that.
I don't think that that really
fits in with how they're meant
to used on Android, but
certainly it's something
that's become popularized.
So the current guidelines don't
really call for exposing
drawers in deeper levels, but
it's definitely something that
we can explore.
If you guys have feedback or
arguments either way in this
direction, feel free
to speak up.
NICK BUTCHER: It's my position
that it's kind of dictated by
the content somewhat.
If you have a strong hierarchy
to your content, then I feel
like the up button should always
take you up through
that hierarchy of content,
and it shouldn't be
exposing the drawer.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
That's fair.
Anybody else?
Any other thoughts?
Actually, this is one thing
that's pretty common right now
is using the drawer for global
access and using, instead of
the up icon or the up counter
in the app icon, using the
three horizontal lines.
And I know you guys can't
really see who's talking
because I'm sharing the
hangout screen, but--
Something like that is a little
more common on other
platforms, and so it's
definitely something that I
think that we should try to
standardize on at some point
in the future.
Actually, a little point about
the three horizontal lines is
somebody called that the
hamburger icon, because it's
basically two buns and meat
patty in between.
But yeah, it's definitely
something that's been used
throughout, and I think that
users understand what it is,
the three horizontal lines,
but really the current
guidelines are for the app
icon and the up counter.
Well, let me just jump into some
of the unofficial stuff
before I take this screen
off, so you can
see our faces again.
So, like the current guidelines
say, only at the
top level, the up counter and
app icon, it should also not
slide the action bar.
So this is a point
of contention.
This is definitely something
that is a little inconsistent
right now across Google Apps.
So the Google+ app, for example,
does slide the action
bar out of the way to make
room for the drawer.
The YouTube app does not.
We definitely recommend not
sliding the action bar out of
the way, and I think there's
really two reasons for that.
The first is that, from a
framework standpoint, from the
development standpoint,
it's actually kind of
difficult to do that.
And it kind of imposes extra
effort and extra work to get
that done, and some people say,
in that case, let's just
recreate the action bar.
Let's just reimplement the
action bar so that we can
slide it out of the way.
And that's not really something
that you should be
doing, because there's a lot of
nuances with how the action
bar's implemented.
So you should try to avoid
implementing the
action bar on your own.
The other point is that the
action bar is really kind of a
core navigational anchor.
It's really the number one
structural component of an
app, I'd say.
And so moving that out of the
way slowly deteriorates this
relationship the user has
with that action bar.
Making sure that it's stable is
very, very important, and
if you start moving it out of
the way and sliding it away
and so on, that could
potentially deteriorate the
experience.
So those are the two points that
I'd say about sliding the
action bar.
And then, again, edge swipe or
full swipe, and then the other
thing that folks sometimes put
into the navigation drawer is
things like settings and help.
And we really don't recommend
putting things like settings
and help there, because those
are really meant to be in the
action overflow.
The action overflow is those
three vertical dots in the
action bar that, when you press
them, you see additional
actions that you can take.
And so settings, help, about,
feedback, terms of service,
privacy policy, things like
that, those are really
overflow items.
And so we feel that those should
belong in an action
overflow and not in the
navigation drawer.
So these are the unofficial
other items I'd add to our
official guidelines.
But certainly--
let me just turn off the
screen share there--
in terms of where we're going
with the guidelines, I think
that there's definitely a lot
that we can add to the current
set of guidelines, and that's
something that we'll be doing
in the future.
It's just a question of
time and resources.
So hopefully at some point,
we'll do that.
Anybody have any other
thoughts on
the navigation drawer?
I just did a big spiel and took
a lot of time to talk
about it, but if you have
any thoughts, feel
free to speak up.
ADAM KOCH: One quick thing I
wanted to mention is how you
said, don't move the action
bar out of the way.
That works in with how you also
mentioned that settings,
about how it should be
in the overflow.
I see a lot of people put those
things in their drawer,
because they've slid across the
action bar, and now the
overflow's no loner
accessible.
So that's another good reason
to keep the action bar in
place so that you can keep
that overflow still
accessible.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NICK BUTCHER: Keep it to
navigation option as well.
I think, because you have this
extra real estate, people get
tempted to dump all sorts of
extra information in there.
And I think that really waters
down the power as a
navigational tool.
I tend to think of it as very
similar to the spinner
navigation like you might see
in Google Maps, for example.
It's a similar thing, but if
you have a larger list of
items, it can become unwieldy
in that spinner
and harder to do.
So I think the draw can be a
good alternative there, as
well as not sacrificing
some real estate.
So don't be tempted to just
chuck any old thing in there
because you have some more
space and a vertically
scrolling container.
JUHANI LEHTIMAKI: So I'm just
wondering if you guys have had
any chance to do any usability
testing of how users see the
site navigation with the
context of back button.
Because I know if you guys
tried the [? Word ?]
application, I don't know if
they fixed it, but when it
first launched, the site
navigation actually was very
difficult to use because
it didn't make sense.
When you backed, you actually
had to skip screens.
I think the Google application
is quite good, but I don't
know if I'm just a special user
or how users in general
feel where the back should take
you after you navigate
within the site menu.
ROMAN NURIK: I don't know too
much about the research we've
done specifically around
navigation drawers.
I'm sure that we've done some
amount of research, but I
don't really know the details.
I know we did a whole bunch of
research on the action bar and
up icon, and that was
a few years ago.
Maybe two years ago we did a big
study on that, but I think
that a lot of our guidance is
a result of direct user
testing with that.
But the navigation drawer, I'm
not really sure what kind of
formal testing we've
done on it.
So I don't really know how
to answer that question.
NICK BUTCHER: I think a lot
of the weirdness with back
navigation falls out from
whether or not you make it
globally accessible as well,
because if you have
applications such as, say,
Spotify or something like
that, which let's you get to the
side drawer from anywhere,
then you can build up these
incredibly long back stacks,
which gets quite complicated.
Whereas if you do stick to the
guidelines, Roman's unofficial
guidelines, of only making it
available from top level
navigation screens, then you
don't get these very, very
complex navigation stacks, and
I think the back button
becomes a lot clearer.
ROMAN NURIK: That's
a fair point.
Do you guys have any thoughts?
Again, since this is a kind of
a discussion and Q&A, I don't
want to just be spewing out
recommendations from our team.
I'd love to hear you guys'
thoughts on what's the right
way to do it, or even like, if
you don't like the up icon,
and this is definitely something
that's been brought
up before, if you don't like
using the up icon or the up
counter for this purpose, what
are the things have you
thought about, and
things like that.
So this is not just for
official guidance.
If you guys have thoughts,
please do share.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, Ed Lee in
the comments chimes in that
the burger menu is getting
quite common.
Even Chrome uses the icon.
ROMAN NURIK: What?
NICK BUTCHER: I think
Chrome uses the icon
in, is it in iOS?
CHRIS BANES: Yes.
ROMAN NURIK: Oh, the
hamburger icon.
They use that on the desktop
basically for the overflow.
I'd say it's a little
different.
You can't really compare two
very distinct platforms.
Like if you look at the desktop
platform verses
Android, there are definitely
different norms on each.
So even the iconography, even
the direction of if there's a
search icon, where
the handle is.
Is it to the left
or to the right?
Even little things like
that, they can
differ across platforms.
So I'd say that it's more
important, I'd say, to be
consistent with Android rather
than consistent across
different platforms.
NICK BUTCHER: So yeah, it's
not in Chrome, sorry.
It's on google.com.
If you go to google.com on
mobile, you get the burger.
[INAUDIBLE].
ROMAN NURIK: That's fair.
MARIE SCHWEIZ: Mostly, if I see
swiping navigations, I'm
cleaning the concept.
People are sending me concepts
and want feedback from me, and
I say mostly it's messy to put
all the functionality in this
menu, and everything is fine.
And if you have something like
a shopping application, they
do the whole functionality for a
shopping basket and all this
stuff in the swipe menu.
And then they want a secondary
action bar to handle
functionalities for the
shopping basket
and all this stuff.
And mostly, if you're cleaning
up the navigation, the
secondary action bar is gone.
That's what I learned
in the past.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, I mean,
using the drawer as the main
navigation, I use it
as a last resource.
I mean, if you don't have any
other way to show visually on
the app the sections,
go there.
But I think it's very, very easy
to just throw everything
in there and forget about it.
And--
MARIE SCHWEIZ: It's not right.
MALE SPEAKER: It's not right,
because the users
are not seeing it.
And if the users are not seeing,
they're probably not
going to remember that
that is there.
So I think it's a trend.
It's obviously a trend.
A lot of people are using it.
MARIE SCHWEIZ: I
don't think so.
I think it's like, OK, we don't
know how we build real
mobile use cases, and then we
put all the menu and we have
the whole system on Android.
ROMAN NURIK: But it
is a trend, right?
It's definitely a trend that
folks are doing it.
And I think that, like AJ says,
it's becoming more and
more like a default.
And what it should be is
really a last resort.
And I think that there are two
points I want to make there.
The first is that sometimes
there are drawers that have
three items in the left pane.
You swipe it open, and there's
three items there.
Drawers are really just
replacements for
tabs in that case.
So it's really just an
alternative presentation of
horizontal tabs at the
top of screen.
And so at that point, why don't
you just simply use tabs
or use a spinner?
I mean, that's less
heavy weight and
more immediately visible.
And the other point I wanted to
make is that this actually
reminds me of one of the
problems that we saw with
original menu button
on older devices.
One of the problems was that
people were putting core
functionality into something
that wasn't immediately
visible and something that
wasn't immediately clear what
functionality was available.
And so you would press the
Menu button and hope that
there's interesting stuff in
there, hope that the thing
that you're trying to do is
in there, and it wasn't
immediately on screen.
One of the reasons we actually
came up with the action bar
pattern was to put more
fundamental actions and
navigation on screen.
And I think that with the
drawer, we're seeing kind of
the reverse of that.
We're putting less and less
stuff on screen for the
purposes of making
or optimizing the
real estate for content.
But I think that there's
probably a better balance to
be struck in a lot of cases
between content and Chrome.
You still want to show the key,
most important navigation
in some way, as well
as your content.
But I'd say that what
AJ says is right.
It shouldn't be a default.
It should really be kind
of a last resort.
If there's no other pattern that
works really well, then
the drawer may be an option.
MARIE SCHWEIZ: It was because
the product managers say, we
want catalog in our shopping
application.
We want a category view.
We want all the stuff we want
in this little small
application, and then
you have too much.
They can develop a mobile
application with maybe three
useful functionalities.
That's the mobile case.
That's the reason why
we have mobile.
I'm maybe in a store, and I will
order the shoes at home,
delivery service.
So one case, just ordering.
And I think the messy point,
or the too much
functionalities, it's a little
bit Windows Explorer.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, I think it's
really up to us as the
designers to talk to folks
like that and say, you do
really need to optimize around
the core competencies and core
best use cases of your app.
Like, make sure that the two or
three things that users are
expecting to do with your
app are really easy and
straightforward.
And if folks that are asking
for these apps to be built
say, but we need like seven,
eight, nine different
functions, then I guess it's
the job of the designers to
say, given those nine functions,
how do we best
present these not as functions
but has as flows and as
benefits to the user.
So I'd say, maybe it's our job
to pare things down to the
most important, and then
put other things in.
Put other items like secondary
functions into the overflow or
into other navigational
elements.
MARIE SCHWEIZ: I agree.
NICK BUTCHER: I quite like it
when an app has a tight focus
and doesn't try to
do everything.
Why not launch a second
app, perhaps,
for a different thing?
MARIE SCHWEIZ: Yeah, or you have
the tablet case, more on
application and more
functionalities on tablet.
CHRIS BANES: That's
true, actually,
you've mentioned tablets.
Also it makes it easier to do
a master detail flow on
tablets, because you can show
that drawer by default on a
tablet, and you have that same
UI, so you can reuse
everything, so it just
makes it easier.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, and YouTube
does that really
nicely as well.
So it uses this responsive
design so when you have a
certain amount of horizontal
real estate, the drawer is
opened by default.
CHRIS BANES: There are
positives to it.
MARIE SCHWEIZ: What I've said
in the past is, OK, other
systems like iOS working
really straight.
They're working a step deeper,
deeper, deeper in the
application, and Android works a
little bit more chaotic, but
every time, step very
close to the user.
ROMAN NURIK: Marie,
still there?
I think Marie may have frozen.
MALE SPEAKER: She's frozen.
ROMAN NURIK: OK, well.
When she gets back, we'll let
her finish that thought.
But before we move on-- we
have five minutes left--
does anybody else have any?
NICK BUTCHER: I think
there will be
moderator questions, or?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, we
should probably
jump into the moderator.
When we return, she can
finish her thought.
Before I jump into the
moderator, does anybody else
have anything they'd
like to bring up?
MALE SPEAKER: Can I talk about
the quick return bar?
ROMAN NURIK: Sure,
yeah, go ahead.
MALE SPEAKER: There's basically,
the pattern that
you presented in the code, and
I shared one that does an
implementation like in Google+
where it's on the bottom.
NICK BUTCHER: OK, Lars did
one of those, right?
Lars forked it.
MALE SPEAKER: Sorry,
what was that?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, Lars forked
your code, didn't he?
Roman, what's his name?
ROMAN NURIK: Lars Vogel?
NICK BUTCHER: [? Birkman ?].
ROMAN NURIK: Oh, Lars,
[? Birkman ?], OK.
That's cool.
I haven't seen it yet.
So Dandre, did you want to
make a point about its
usefulness, or do you have
any questions about it?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, I was
curious, like, so there's a
little bit of weirdness about
scrolling up bringing
something from the bottom, but
the advantage, of course, is
that it's on the bottom,
so it's a lot
closer to your finger.
Maybe if you were scrolling
up, you'd just scroll up a
little, and it's right there.
And if you're on a tablet or
something, or if you scroll
up, and the thing's
at the top, then
it's really far away.
So I was curious, what's the
ideas about, should it be on
the top or bottom, or
if it were just a
weird pattern at all.
ROMAN NURIK: Well, I think
that the placement, it's
generally better to
put it at the top.
It's a little more natural.
I'd say that the Google+ app in
general, when talking about
things that Google+ app does,
it's a little more
experimental on the UI side.
They're definitely trying lots
and lots of those things.
And some of them work
really well.
Some of them are really
just experiments that
they'll pull out.
So I wouldn't say that follow
the Google+ app to the T as to
what it does.
But specifically in this case,
I think one of the reasons
that they moved it down is that
the iconography that they
were using wasn't as clear as
it could be, and then they
wanted to show text as well.
And then at that point, the bar
itself became quite large.
So it became just a little bit
of a burden at the very top of
the screen.
So they moved it to the bottom,
but I don't think that
that's really finalized.
I don't really know
if it's finalized.
But certainly it's something
that we're still exploring,
but I'd say that by default, you
should probably use sticky
bars at the top unless it's
really following your
scrolling gesture.
So if you're scrolling down and
you want to show something
at the very bottom like, for
example, I don't know if this
is very common, but jump to the
top or jump to the bottom.
If it's showing up in the
direction you're scrolling,
that would probably
make sense.
So, if you're scrolling up,
probably showing something at
the top is better.
NICK BUTCHER: One exception
that I quite like is the
Foursquare app does something
quite nice where, as you're
scrolling down your feed, if
you go back to the top, it
actually pops up some kind of
filters at the bottom, which
is actually a quite nice
way of doing it.
So it doesn't do it just with
the general scrolling up, but
just when you reach the
very top, it pops in,
which I quite like.
ROMAN NURIK: That's fair.
Marie, did you want to finish
your thought real quick?
MARIE SCHWEIZ: My network is
not really stable today.
ROMAN NURIK: That's all right.
We'll follow up over
on Google+.
MARIE SCHWEIZ: No problem.
I see that you can handle
the topic very careful.
ROMAN NURIK: So let's see.
Dandre, did you have any other
questions on the quick return?
It's not really a formalized
pattern, the quick return, and
actually that name is just
something that me and Nick
came up with.
It's not really a
formal thing.
But certainly, I think, in
general when there's something
that's not documented in our
official guidelines, we have a
bug filed internally to make
sure that it gets documented.
It's just a question of
time and resources.
So at some point, we'll have
probably some more guidance on
quick return.
MARIE SCHWEIZ: I have a question
about resources.
ROMAN NURIK: Sure.
MARIE SCHWEIZ: So mostly, I'm
working for-- in the past--
now I'm employed by Novoda, but
in the past, I'm working
for a lot of creative
agencies.
They're doing something like
catalog, or shopping, or
tools, or gadgets, or
automotive, or sports brands,
all this stuff.
And I try to show them
how Android works.
Big thanks to my friend
[INAUDIBLE]
who took maybe 30 screen shots
from Ice Cream Sandwich.
And I have now 30 screenshots
with his private mail account
and all the private stuff.
But I use this stuff to show
the [INAUDIBLE] and the
designers, look how
Android is today.
And what I really need is maybe
just screenshots from an
actual system, a Nexus 4.
I haven't done Nexus 4.
I have just older phones.
I prefer the older phones
actually, not just because
they have keyboards.
ROMAN NURIK: I think AJ is
signing an agreement, right?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, I mean,
right now, it's really hard to
find screenshots of the
Nexus 10 resolution.
You can't find it.
I can't.
There are no--
MARIE SCHWEIZ: Or just how a
system application looks.
MALE SPEAKER: When [INAUDIBLE]
HTPA comes in, you'd better,
guys, have a couple of
screenshots first.
ROMAN NURIK: I will say this.
So if there are specific
screenshots
that you guys need--
I mean, it's obvious that we
can't all buy every device.
If you guys need certain
screenshots at any point, just
let us know publicly.
We'll share publicly.
We're more than happy
to do that.
And we have a bunch
of test accounts.
So I know that this isn't like
an official resource, but this
is definitely something
that we can help
with in one off cases.
But certainly, we do plan on
updating the design site with
this kind of stuff.
So I don't know if it will
be full resolution, but
certainly, we want to make sure
the design set is up to
date so that you can share at
least those screenshots, those
framed screenshots with
your product managers
and clients and such.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I'd always
say whenever I start working
with a designer whose not worked
with Android before, I
always encourage them, if they
can, get hold of a device and
just get used to the
patterns and so on.
I know that might not be
possible, depending on your
clients or whatever it is, but
that's going to be the first,
best solution.
If not, there's always
the emulator, but--
MARIE SCHWEIZ: I can tell you,
from time to time, I never get
my device back.
ROMAN NURIK: I think we're
losing our room, and I think
we're a little over time.
So let's stop there and
continue sometime in
the next few weeks.
I think we should do more of
these, and probably on deeper
dives into specific subjects.
But thanks everybody for
joining, and definitely we
have food for thought and more
bugs to file in terms of more
design research things
to come out with.
So again, thanks for joining,
and we'll see you
hopefully next week.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARIE SCHWEIZ: Bye.